the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC the scary part is that Herschel
Walker had a chance and he almost won
I've been saying now for months that
Herschel Walker never should have even
had a shot in a country that made sense
with voters with some connection to
reality someone like Herschel Walker
never should have even won the
Republican nomination in Georgia to be
Senator never mind getting 49 of the
vote roughly uh in the general election
in Georgia which is what happened in the
runoff and there's a couple of good
articles and one that I want to
highlight in particular that makes this
case Jack Holmes wrote a couple days ago
in Esquire Herschel Walker lost but it's
a very bad sign that he had any chance
at all there was a shark in the pool and
nobody got bit
but why were so many people cheering for
the shark in the pool and the article
makes points that are not altogether
surprising but the point that we've been
making and that Jack Holmes makes is
that although it's a good thing that
Herschel Walker lost he barely did and
the fact that he almost became one of
100 senators in the United States is
certainly emblematic and indicative of a
much bigger and scarier problem in the
United States and uh in the article Jack
Holmes writes it feels almost
unnecessary at this point to run through
Herschel Walker's record as a national
political candidate he's running in
Georgia but said in a campaign speech he
lives in Texas etc etc but as you read
down the article
it explains the answer for a lot of
people to the question why make Herschel
Walker a senator seem to be that if
Walker wasn't elected those people
Democrats marxists you know who the hell
knows would control the Senate and by
the time that the election came up on
Tuesday that was no longer the issue
because we knew that at minimum
Democrats would have a 50-50 majority
with Kamala Harris as the tie-breaking
vote
um and so it became more about who gets
power and who do Republicans vote for
and what are the principles here and who
are the backers of this guy and when you
zoom out and you think about what
happened you realize that this was
really the worst of the worst of
Republican politics at this point in
time what do I mean by that well it's
basically at least three different
things number one
for many Republican voters
and for the GOP establishment the RNC
at the end of the day it's simply about
is there a Democrat that we can prevent
from winning somewhere it doesn't matter
who we put in place so the no Democrats
ever is a big part of this and later on
in this in this part of the show we're
actually going to look at a republican
who is saying it's not about no
Democrats no matter what it actually
does depend who the Republican is and
Mitt Romney is that guy we'll get to
that a little bit later so you've got
the the lesson warnocks the Democrat we
can't have that that's number one number
two you have the maganon Maga split so
it has to be acknowledged that the other
Factor here is that Herschel Walker is
sort of a Maga cult type candidate and
as we know from following Trump in 2016
and 2020 and into 2022's midterms
through his endorsements and now as a
2024 candidate it is a cult and one of
the things about the cult is when the
cult leader tells you this is the guy in
this particular case uh you accept that
you accept that and you don't question
it and Donald Trump said this is is the
guy and it failed fortunately but the
magicalists accepted it so that's
another layer to this you've got better
than a Democrat no matter what
cult candidate okay and then you have
the third part of this which is the
voters more broadly and this goes beyond
cult or not cult but it's the general
problem in the United States of how
there really is no bar
there's no bar for
the majority of the Republican
electorate big picture now that doesn't
mean they'll literally vote for anyone
in a primary but Trump 2016 was
instructive of that why did Trump run as
a Republican and not as a Democrat he
really was at least Loosely speaking a
Democrat it seems most of his life
but it was because there is some
standard on the Democratic party side
it's not anyone can get the nomination
just if they come up with the right
things to say even if they completely
contradict 68 years of their lives as
did Trump on issues of religion and
abortion and other things the Republican
party has no such bar and so because of
that we saw that they were gullible
enough to go for it in 2016 and then it
was sort of a path dependence that got
them there in 2020 as well those are
really the three things that this is
about and as it applies to Herschel
Walker we're all glad he lost Herschel
Walker in the U.S Senate would be a
humiliation to this country and it would
be a humiliation in so many different
ways great we dodged the bullet and not
by very much I think it's important to
say under a hundred thousand votes if
I'm recalling correctly but
he had a shot and as we saw in 2016 with
Trump sometimes you don't Dodge the
bullet and then in 20 we did Dodge it
and so let's not take away there's
people emailing me saying
we made it we made it the 2022 midterms
they weren't as bad as they could have
been yes they weren't as bad as they
could have been but they were almost so
bad that they could be that bad or worse
in 2024 we don't want to allow that to
happen Donald Trump's Jewish allies are
begging him begging him to condemn Kanye
West and Trump is reportedly refusing
there's a very good article in Rolling
Stone Trump's Jewish allies are begging
him to condemn Kanye he's refusing
prominent Jewish and human rights
leaders are circulating a letter asking
the former president to distance himself
from Kanye West and Nick Fuentes they
were the people that had the the dinner
with Trump the other day a trump advisor
responds I've seen it and I do not care
I encourage you to read the entire
article there's a couple different
things that are important to talk about
here number one it is appalling Apollo
following that Trump still has Jewish
friends that in and of itself doesn't
make any sense whatsoever oh but David
sir the uh his his daughter converted to
Judaism and his grandkids none of that
this is not about that it's not even
really about Trump's personal beliefs
about Jews although sure I mean I think
we kind of have a sense of what they are
but it's about the factions that Trump
gives credibility to by not denouncing
or condemning now to really understand a
lot of the entire Jewish Republican
thing this is as good an opportunity as
any to remind folks in the audience that
support for Israel
in the vague way that Evangelical
Christians quote support Israel and
support for American Jews could not
possibly be more dramatically different
things okay
right-wing support for Israel is
primarily based in
evangelicals who believe for biblical
reasons that Jews running Israel is a
step towards the return of Jesus Christ
now I know some of you will say and I'm
realizing I don't have my headphone on
and I'm going to need it for the next
segment I'm just going to put it on
while we chat there are people who will
say oh but David these folks love Israel
they just they love love Israel they
love it not because of any concern for
anti-Semitism or anti-jewish
discrimination or whatever the case may
be they love it because they see it as a
path to the bringing back Jesus that's
what it is American Jews have completely
different beliefs and ideas etc etc and
just because you see a right winger a
Republican cow Towing to Israel in the
particular sense that Evangelical
Christians like it doesn't mean that
they are supportive of American Jews or
for even understand never mind are going
to fight against anti-Semitism so that's
number one
unfortunately some Republican Jews
ignore that
and they throw in support with
Republican candidates fortunately It's
relatively few because American Jews are
one of the most left-wing voting blocs
in the country uh American Jews black
folks two of the most left-wing voting
groups Trump also has black allies right
so it's not completely uh incredible
that he is Jewish allies as well even
though if even though it doesn't really
make any sense based on policy but the
most important aspect of this to
understand is Trump sees people
as objects tools or a means to an end
and we saw when those folks are no
longer useful to him he dumps them
flushes them 10 to 15 times and
unfortunately there are certain people
that don't get this and they get tricked
and we're seeing it now once again with
Jewish voters but it seems this may be
the end of the line for Trump's Jewish
supporters we'll see there will always
be some Mitt Romney was asked the other
day will you vote for Trump if he's the
2024 Republican nominee this is an
interesting question because there are
many Republicans who are starting to say
things like I would rather a different
nominee I would prefer that we just
nominate someone different and that it
not be up to me to decide on Election
Day do I vote for Trump or not let's
just pick a different nominee Mitt
Romney is speaking with a Clarity that
many Republicans are not speaking with
now this is not a look at how great Mitt
Romney is story this is a look at how
low the bar is story Mitt Romney is
clearly saying I would not support Trump
even if he were the number money in
2024. it's going to be hard to to knock
him off as our nominee if he became a
nominee I think he loses again and um
would you support him if he's the
nominee absolutely not uh and I mean I
get asked that I mean how
look I I voted to remove him from Office
twice so uh I knew what your answer is
but the answer is and it's not just
because he he loses I mean that's that's
my reason that I offer to other people
who are big fans of his but but it's
also he's he's simply not a person who
ought to have the reins of the
government the United States okay very
very clear Romney says it's not just
about I'd rather a different nominee if
he's the nominee I'm not voting for him
compare and contrast this with some of
the more spineless people in the
Republican Party William Barr William
Bart one of Trump's former attorney
generals Attorneys General said uh this
guy was a threat to democracy all these
horrible horrible things but I don't
know I mean if it's a Democrat I might
still have to vote for him
listen to this well I certainly have
made it clear I don't think he should be
our nominee and I'm going to you know
support somebody else for the nomination
but if he is the nominee and you have
your choice is
Donald Trump or whoever's running on the
Democratic side would you vote for him
uh because I believe that the the
greatest threat to the country is the
progressive agenda being pushed by the
Democratic party it's inconceivable to
me that I wouldn't vote for the
Republican nominee wow wow threat to
democracy dangerous no business has no
clue what's going on but I mean that
Savannah please a Democrat I'm not going
to vote for a Democrat that would be
even worse and then Mitch McConnell even
who Trump has called his wife
I don't remember if Trump called his
wife ugly but he certainly called her
different names has attacked him as a
rhino just up and down slamming
McConnell even McConnell what was it 10
days ago when he was asked he played koi
with it and didn't rule it out in light
of what you said that there's no room in
your party for anyone Harbors these
anti-semitic views if Donald Trump wins
the Republican nomination would you
support him
look let me just say again
there is simply no room in the
Republican party for anti-Semitism or
white supremacy and that would apply to
all of the leaders in the party who will
be seeking officers there you go so even
Mitch McConnell not ruling it out the
bar is very low
and Mitt Romney has exceeded that bar
make sure that you are subscribed to the
David Pacman Show YouTube channel it is
free unlike with voting and elections if
you have five Google accounts you can
subscribe five times to the YouTube
channel and I encourage you to do it
let's get to to 2 million we'll take a
quick break and be right back
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at a fair price
guys know how tough it can be to find
good boxers and t-shirts the Search is
Over All boxer briefs by Leisure of NYC
are made with amazingly soft moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo it feels
super lightweight like air it doesn't
Bunch up it's also great for the planet
Leisure of NYC also makes these
incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's the best out there it
feels like Silk quite frankly you can
walk around in a scratchy t-shirt all
day or you can enjoy the cloud soft feel
of supima cotton and actually love the
shirt you're in these are my go-to
shirts and boxers nobody else even comes
close to the Comfort they provide all
products are fair trade with
sustainability in mind pick some up for
yourself or someone on your holiday
shopping list go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
the David pakman show does depend truly
on the support of our viewers and
listeners through the membership program
now there is a particular person his
name is Alex Jones he hates the entire
membership thing oh the bonus show where
you want to make money yeah everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad I consider it an endorsement that
Alex Jones hates it and I encourage you
to sign up at
joinpakman.com
let's go to our audience and hear from
some of you such an important week covid
recovery of mine the Herschel Walker
loss in Georgia and so many important
things I want to hear from you we take
calls via Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord and we are going to start today
with Chuck from Pennsylvania Chuck what
is on your mind today
uh can you hear me David I can loud and
clear my friend
all right cool uh yeah I just wanted to
say you know I I my faith in humanity or
the US has been slightly restored with
the uh the Walker loss has it really
though because he almost won you know
what I mean it's like I get I'm with you
in the sense that if we imagine in
America today with senator-elect
Herschel Walker and then we we say oh we
avoided that of course that that that's
good but the guy almost won like that's
extraordinarily depressing
yeah yeah I mean it like you said it's
it's depressing at the same time because
I don't know how many he had like he got
like two million votes and and he only
won by like what was it 48 51 yeah the
split or something like that yeah but uh
anyway uh so yeah slightly but still
depressing
um but no it's sort of like a food for
thought or just like something that I've
thought about like
so you know how like the right
um they're they're against all the
electric car like any push for green
energy stuff like that yeah uh they want
to stick in their traditional ways
um so I've thought about like in you
know 50 100 years however many years I
don't know but do you see maybe like the
Republican Party becoming like the sort
of like a small group almost like the
Amish where they're kind of just shunned
because they're stuck in their ways and
uh like total technological luddites or
something yeah yeah yeah like just
they're still using their diesel trucks
and using Kohl's to burning coal for
energy in their small little community
and they're stuck in their religious
ways listen it's not impossible because
think about it you know they're against
all sorts of
um medical research that certainly is
going to lead to advancements and it's
totally plausible that they will sort of
shun taking availing themselves of some
of that we're seeing it with vaccines
already right they're all we see this
huge anti-backs movement so they're
already self-selecting selecting out
there they seem to love just burning
gasoline in their vehicles for for
whatever reason and they consider it
manly and culturally relevant and
whatever else so maybe they will resist
that as well the way I think it might
happen is at a certain point it seems
the direction things are going is that
new vehicles sold will have to be
electric but like if you can keep an
existing
um if you can keep an existing uh ice
vehicle on the road then you can keep
driving it or something so it'll almost
it might become kind of like how in Cuba
because of the Embargo a lot of the cars
are really really old the American cars
and they just have to keep maintaining
them because that's what they have it
might end up being something sort of
like that
yeah yeah I mean you know they may end
up being forced with like the car thing
because once they get older you know
there won't be parts for the old ice and
they'll all be electric or something
like that but I mean even just as far as
like you what you were saying with like
medicine and stuff like I knew like the
Amish communities now like they don't go
to regular dentists and stuff like some
of them so like they all end up like
their teeth brought out and stuff so I
don't know it was just something I kind
of thought uh kind of like uh it's all I
see similarities sort of thing yeah I I
absolutely do and I don't think it would
become listen to become like the Amish
it's going to take a much much much
longer time
um but uh the idea of it I completely
understand
yeah that was all I had though all right
Chuck from Pittsburgh thank you
very powerful phone call I appreciate it
just as a reminder if you want to get on
to talk to me in the Discord your
nickname has to be your name and where
you're calling from or where you're
calling from and your name uh all of the
different nicknames that are in there
you are self-selecting out because it's
just not the right format very very
important to understand let's go to is
it Lewis from New Brunswick or Lois it's
just cut off I apologize
something with an Lo from New Brunswick
oh good afternoon David it's uh Louie
Louie welcome what's on your mind today
well I just want to thank you I love
your show thank you been listening for a
long time pleasure uh a couple months
ago you had a piece with author
Jefferson Morley yes
he's known for JFK research and stuff um
my question for you is
do you think the uh the government's
response to the JFK case which a lot of
I guess polls show that a lot of people
are a little skeptical
on the official conclusions uh do you
think that's fueled all of this
recent uh I I don't know how to say it
uh destabilization with like conspiracy
theories and just lack of like General
consensus you're saying is the lack of
credibility of the government's position
on the JFK assassination fueling other
modern conspiracy theorism
yeah do you think it like it it like
laid a a groundwork that or we haven't
really reaped the full of uh uh you know
damage of until now I don't think so I
don't think so I mean there's
interesting stuff going on with JFK
right now in fact I recorded a tick tock
earlier this week which we're going to
publish in Jefferson Morley wrote about
recently how on December 15th I believe
it is is the deadline imposed a year ago
by the Biden Administration to release a
whole bunch of new documents and we'll
see about the JFK assassination and
we'll see if they are or aren't and
there are some who are saying this is
going to be an incredible bombshell or
something like that I don't know I don't
think that no I I don't think that the
JFK assassination specifically
um has much to do with with modern
conspiracism I think it's lack of
critical thinking social media Echo
Chambers people who don't know how to
think for themselves and evaluate claims
lack of epistemological skills I I think
it's all of that really
oh interesting all right thanks a lot I
appreciate the call all right Louie from
New Brunswick thank you very very much
for the call let's go to Grant from Ohio
Grant welcome to the program what's on
your mind today hey David um I was just
wondering if you could give your
thoughts um because I don't think you've
talked about it yet about the Biden and
um his administration not siding with
the railroad uh unions when I believe
all they wanted was paid sick leave and
uh there was an interesting interview I
think Jake Tapper did a pretty good
interview with Pete Buda judge another
couple days of grilling them on it but
um I just find it kind of hypocritical
because Biden says he's the best
pro-union
and labor president or a lifetime but
he's not signing with the railroad
workers and all they want is paid sick
leave so listen a lot of that was
happening as I was sort of falling into
my covid uh uh fit period and so I did
not follow the story as closely as I
would have liked but my understanding of
the Biden position on this was listen
they're not getting everything but
they're getting a bunch of stuff they
want and it's really important to
prevent the strike now you can take the
position
that the Biden Administration
should not be
forcefully working in any way to prevent
a strike particularly if they claim to
support both unions and workers rights
to strike and I am very sympathetic to
that idea but it seems that the argument
that the Biden Administration is making
is
if this strike were to happen here are
all of the ways in which it would be a
disaster for different aspects of the
American people because of the Reliance
that is that is taking place on
railroads and a lot of their demands
were met
and so we think that they should not
strike but I think it's perfectly
legitimate to say that it's a government
overreach to actually prevent the strike
I agree with that too and it's also
frustrating when these CEOs and like the
leaders of these railroads are making
record profits too and
um yeah I just think it's frustrating it
is absolutely frustrating there's no
doubt about that
all right well that was all thank you
all right thanks Grant there is Grant we
will next go to Samir from Metro Detroit
welcome to the program am I can ask
pronouncing that correctly
uh sammer sammer okay apologies what's
on your mind today Sam I know where it
is uh so I had a basic question so I
know you've been on uh Fox News before
would you ever go back on and debate
Tucker Carlson sure his show I mean
here's the thing when people ask me
would you debate X Y or Z person it's
like yeah but about what you know what I
mean the thing about these debates is
and in particularly on the Tucker show
like I would do the Tucker thing just
for the publicity because it would be
great publicity but they set you up to
fail they give you an absurdly limited
amount of time in general and then limit
the amount of time that you're able to
speak you're given they can talk
overview because of over you because of
how the microphones are configured
you're set up with extremely narrow and
unfairly framed questions like it's very
difficult to show up and come off
looking like you really achieved
anything you know but for the publicity
and for the story I assure I would do it
but but the other question is about what
you know like for example
what should U.S policy be on Ukraine
Russia I'm not an expert in that issue
you know I follow the story and try to
be as informed as possible but it's it's
also about like what are we going to
talk about you know the Twitter files
might be a more interesting story you
know we we do much more media type
stories and the Twitter files is a big
media story where it was billed as this
bombshell and it flopped and so so would
I debate him sure but it would have to
be a topic that makes sense
yeah that that sounds about that's
pretty uh yeah it makes sense
um one other question uh so you I know
you drive a Tesla right now and you said
you're not gonna get another one when
you return your lease that's right what
are you looking at in uh as your next
vehicle uh I'm not really looking yet I
mean uh I'm gonna stick with electric
but I think it'll be based on what's
available at the time and depending on
when I get out of the lease you know if
an opportunity appears to get out of the
lease without having to pay 4 500 bucks
which is what I'd have to pay right now
um I would do it sooner but I know that
in 23 there's new vehicles coming with
longer ranges and so I'll just have to
evaluate what's available at the time
I I just know that lead times are pretty
uh I work in automotive and so I know
that yes it's really really difficult to
get a vehicle right now that is also
true if I wait if I wait they might say
well it's going to be nine months or
longer before we can even get you the
car so I I don't honestly I don't know
yet
okay well that's all thanks for uh
answering the questions all right Samer
thank you very very much for the call
we're gonna go next to JD right JP
Mandel JD from Little Rock you're on the
air
hey David can you hear me I can you're a
little low but I'll try to pump you up
I can speak up a little bit
um hey I just wanted to call in I work
for a calorie power utility in Little
Rock
um and we just got some interesting
information regarding the North Carolina
uh substation sabotage okay
um we just got a bulletin from the
electricity information sharing and
Analysis Center
um apparently on December 3rd there were
three ballistic attacks at the North
Carolina and North Carolina that have
occurred at two substations
um the attacks were targeting specific
um aspects of the substation that would
lead these this authority to believe
that they were targeted
specifically to do that take these
substations down
um the attacks were all with the same
kind of paladural weapons
and they stand out because they're uh
different than what some of the past
attacks we've seen apparently six
different substations have been attacked
this year in the United States
but they kind of indicate that those
were more seeming to be Lone Wolf and
this kind of General vandalism while
these attacks in North Carolina seem
more orchestrated
okay well we will we will look into it I
have not been following the story
closely but let me investigate all right
sure uh just uh just real quick uh the
it states that they
they have low confidence that the
motivations were motivated by a mix of
ideologies and extremist content
and the links that they provide provide
past articles about links to Neo-Nazi
terrorism and white supremacists
terrorist plots targeting power grids
okay all right JD thank you very much
for the call
no problem okay so there's an update a
very very important update let's go next
to Lucas from Massachusetts Lucas
welcome to the program
hey David I hope you're feeling better
I'm feeling a lot better yeah
glad to hear it okay so here's what I
was going to talk about please the
treadmill yesterday how to try Mill
thought I noticed that this this
information is a lot like the covet
virus and that will never eradicate it
we can take measures to bring it on
under control and we should but doing
zero info like zero code isn't
sustainable if that makes any sense I'd
love to hear what you think
yeah I mean listen but nobody's doing
zero covet anymore I don't know I mean
like sure I'm friends with him for a
while yes right uh but when I look on
Facebook I still see a few people I'm
friends with who seem to be saying we
should be doing something close to zero
covid and everybody wear masks forever
everywhere and all this different stuff
it's it's just not going to happen you
know and I try to focus my conversations
on harm reduction minimize issues ETC
and I do think that we we just have to
be sort of realistic but yeah you can
only do I mean listen way more
Republicans die do we now know because
way fewer Republicans got the vaccine
what were we going to force him to get
vaccinated no but it's it's like you
provide the information you do what you
can
yeah but like with disinformation I I
know you support media literacy courses
and I agree yeah I just think it's very
important because
you're not suppressing all the possible
information like not how to shut off the
internet would not be worth it
um media literacy would really work
almost like a vaccine you know yeah no
you're hopefully inoculating people from
falling for fake news
yeah and like
never got a media literacy course at
school because I'm out of high school
now and in college but
um yeah that's just what I wanted to say
and like I said glad you're feeling
better and I enjoy the show Lucas
powerfully said I appreciate the call
all right take care all right you two
we're gonna take a quick break but we're
still taking calls so if you're holding
on to talk to me don't hang up and then
we'll get right back to the phones in a
moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's go back to the phones by which I
mean Discord we take calls on Fridays at
davidpackman.com
Discord we are going to go next to
Julian in New York City Julian what's
going on
hey David I just um well a couple weeks
ago I heard your interview with Anan
girdardas and the the persuaders book
which I Anand
on on it yeah I guess the emphasis is at
the beginning yeah I got I got it
running two off the air with him Anand
Anand Anon yes Anand wonderful I mean
fantastic
fantastic interviews really I thought
you know one of your best in the past
year but I read his book The persuaders
and one of my favorite sections was
um Democratic messaging or about
Democratic messaging with the recent um
wins in the Senate you know the
expanding the majority all that yep what
do we how do we
um keep pushing Democrats and I guess
larger Progressive communities to to
keep because you know the messaging is
an issue it's still an issue yeah we won
but we we still have this huge problem
that is sort of like a I don't know it's
like a virus that doesn't seem to you
know I guess my question is where is
gonna how do we build this incentive to
keep pushing our community in the right
direction well listen when you say the
message are you talking about messaging
from elected Democrats or from people
ancillary to the Democratic party like
Progressive activists or who what
messaging exactly are you referring to I
think it starts at the top and then
Works its way down I mean it can start
you know anywhere from Bernie and then
and then kind of flows down it's this
it's this uh framing things
conceding these crazy
um made up points that Republicans say
about either the Border or whatever well
give me an example of that so like
whether it's Bernie or whatever what's
what's a point that the left has
conceded On the Border
like Republicans will say okay they're
they're you know so many
um illegal immigrants are crossing the
border and then Democrats will say we're
gonna we're gonna
be just as strong On the Border but
we're also going to make sure that new
jobs and and stuff is being so you know
like in uh encountering that point
they're not they're not um
they're conceding that they're that they
too we too want to be strong at the
border and I guess I mean I think that's
an example because there's an opera so
there's two different issues here it's
the the reason why it's really hard to
say here's the way to frame this and I'm
not a framing guy you need the truth is
you need to figure out what would
actually be effective here there's like
three different issues at the border
that are from a rhetoric standpoint and
a propaganda standpoint one is the story
that the day Trump left and Biden took
over something dramatically changed at
the border that now allows a free flow
of undocumented immigrants over the
border that that did didn't happen right
so that like that's one issue that you
have to deal with number two is the
issue of
it is because of Republicans getting in
the way that significant immigration
reform hasn't been done a lot of
low-hanging fruit could have been dealt
with DACA could have been dealt with
with a path to to citizenship for those
who came here when they weren't even
adults they were just brought here by
parents it's Republicans who have gotten
in the way of that to some degree
because they they see oh we don't want
to give Democrats that Victory or
whatever the case may be so there
there's that issue as well and then
number three
there's the Republican
I don't know what to call it but it's oh
there's an election coming up well then
we should talk about Caravans and then
all of a sudden the day after the
election we don't mention Caravans
anymore and there's an auction coming up
we got to talk about violent crime by
undocumented immigrants the day after
the election they don't talk about it
anymore so there's that Brazen
um uh hypocrisy when it comes to when
they even claim to care it's a lot to
deal with I don't have the right
messaging on it I don't know
yes yeah and I guess to sort of surmise
what I'm what I'm trying to say is it
feels like we're always playing catch-up
with the messaging they say something
they State something it could be
blatantly false and then we don't even
you know disprove it we just go with it
at and yes and rather than um really
putting our foot down and so with the
recent wins that I just I just want to
make sure that we keep a pressure on I
agree with you I just don't know who it
is that is well positioned like maybe
it's Anand I don't know to give some
advice about what should the language be
around some of these issues to fight the
Republican framing which is so dishonest
and inaccurate absolutely yeah well
thanks very much David my pleasure man
all right great to uh great to hear from
Julian in New York City why don't we go
next to oh I don't know how about uh
Rose calling from the United States God
bless the United States Rose welcome to
the program
hey David
um
that sounds great let's start there what
what did you do wrong
um I interrupted you but while you're
talking I have ADHD and sometimes I I do
that um all right we're talking about
space uh so
um here's uh here's my point like I've
been feeling more and more that we're
hurtling towards the future that most of
us aren't even prepared for uh let alone
dreaming dreaming about so
um
are you aware about like the uh General
risk profiler on nuclear proliferation
yeah in fact I recently read the book
precipice by Toby ORD wherein he talks
about existential risks to Homo sapiens
and devotes quite a bit of time uh to to
sort of a nuclear
um I don't know what you would even call
it a nuclear Holocaust for lack of a
better term yes so to some degree I've
read about it yes
so
um there's been back in the 1960s there
was this project called the nits country
project
um where they gave to a grad students
one of them left and so it was in three
three grad students in total
um recently graduated almost no
experience a library and access to basic
technical help and basic calculations uh
this was 1960 so that meant computer
time
and ask them to come up with a working
schematics for an implosion style device
this was like the at the bomb Houston
Nagasaki the fat boy it's like a sphere
of plutonium and explosives explosive
lenses around it and the explosion goes
off in like precise nanosecond timing
yeah and it like compresses the sphere
into a tiny ball and causes fission and
then boom they managed to create a
working model from scratch
in two and a half years they created
working schematic from two and a half
years it was meant to see if how long
would it take a nation state to do this
the NS country
um at a time only the US and the USSR
could do it
most of the information needed to build
a weapon like this has always been open
source it's like 80 year old technology
but the constraint has always been the
materials
but now it feels like it's getting
easier and easier and easier to do it I
was playing with chat GPT yes and I
managed to get it to do certain things
um
including
um automatically generates a certain
things related to uh this technology uh
one might say that it would have
ordinarily taken me
um uh weeks of research to do and it
didn't I'm not sure I know what you're
saying and I'm not sure if there's a
question are you saying that you were in
a conversation with this chat bot chat
GPT you were able to get information
from it which presumably it sourced from
available information about how to build
a nuclear device is that what you're
saying
it's it's synthesized that it took what
it would have been like weeks of
synthesis and did it in 10 seconds
understood and then it kind of like spat
out information about how such a such a
device might be built yeah the
dimensions are different parts and so on
like how to calculate the dimensions of
code for it and so
um and how to simulate it
um
I I feel like a lot of the conversation
that I've had with conservatives and so
on and then the future that they imagine
um it is really disconnected with the
future that we we have and the future
that I'm seeing coming like when I saw
that it actually really shocked me so I
I had this moment of Future Shock you
know like I wish my mom I get it Rose
did did you have a question today
yes what do you feel about this is there
a way to bridge that disconnect is this
is there a which disconnect are you
referring to
uh but
between way to them that hey the food
fighting over
not exactly the most prosaic of issues
no I don't I don't have any insights as
to how one might do that I mean we all
there's I've talked before this idea
where you know if we made first contact
with an intelligent alien species all of
a sudden we would all realize that our
Earthly problems are really quite
meaningless in the grand scheme of
things and finding other intelligent
life and War would end and then you know
I've spoken to enough scientists who say
yeah that wouldn't really happen it
would sort of maybe temporarily do that
and then things would go back to the
exact same uh debates and disagreements
that we have and and people can't uh
sort of more permanently um uh be uh in
in that mindset so I don't have any
great insights as to as to how to
connect people with the potential future
we're hurtling towards I wish I did
thank you so much and I shall read the
book Thank you all right there is Rose
very very important message and making a
lot of different claims I would say
let's go next to Manuel from Florida
Welcome to the program my friend
hello David hello it has been a long
time that's nice to speak to you again
thank you uh let's see I've been
thinking about
sort of the direction of
what is like popular sentiment in
America and it feels like the next
generation is overwhelmingly more
liberal more Progressive
um I I can't I can't cite that right now
I don't have it off the top of my head
you are right generally speaking each
successively younger generation is more
Progressive than the previous for now
that continues to hold true
yeah and but there's also like a lot of
the things that the conservative
side of the spectrum like hold on to are
really old like traditions right that
they go back a long time yes so it
you'll always have that that in some
capacity you know whether it's small or
big on that side of the spectrum
but do you think
they would ever be
I don't know like I don't see it ever
going away but you think it'll come back
like do you think for example Christian
nationalism that it'll truly grow to be
popular or will it always stay kind of
this small Niche I don't think any
prediction I could make about that would
be worth a penny I mean really humans
are so terrible at making these types of
predictions and this is why when Trump
was using the line during his 2020 I
think it was in 2020 he would say we
will never be a socialist country maybe
we will I don't know I mean it it
doesn't seem to be going in that
direction right now but how can we say
the U.S will never be a socialist
country 500 years a thousand years if
the US is still around maybe it will be
a socialist country that being said
right now there's no socialists in power
so it's not going to happen anytime soon
so I I would be very hesitant to make
any Maybe Christian nationalism will
maybe we will be a a fully legal
Christian theocracy at some point in
time I don't know I I would hesitate to
make any of these never Contra uh
predictions
yeah no I feel that I mean this is you
know kind of what a baptism but it I I
was just thinking about it because you
see a lot of people say that Christian
nationalism is a threat so I wonder like
is it a threat insofar as it could
become popular or is it just a threat
insofar as this small group of people
can be very dangerous I think it depends
on who you ask and exactly where and
what year it is but I I think it's fair
to say that Christian nationalism is a
threat in the sense that it threatens
the America that the founding fathers
created that's it's a threat in that
sense and then is it a practical and
imminent threat well there is a group
that if they took power would make
Christian theocracy a reality right now
they thankfully don't have that power
but they are certainly a threat in that
they want more power so it's just about
better defining what we mean by threat
if that makes sense
no yeah that does make sense
yeah I just wanted to hear what your
thoughts were on on that so I appreciate
it again well I appreciate the call very
much things are okay in Florida
oh things are great because the
weather's epic right now we're looking
at like 70 degree weather because like
I'm in California so yeah well I'm
hoping to get down soon and reschedule
this appearance with Patrick Bet David
that I was supposed to do and uh yeah
before you know it I might be back in
Florida
okay awesome yeah I have a Cuban
sandwich right here heavy white a Cuban
sandwich Cuban oh all right yeah well
we'll talk about that let's talk about
the pork later all right okay Manuel
thank you very much for the call
appreciate it that does it for today
we're done for the day with live calls
appreciate everyone I was able to speak
to and we will take live calls again
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
let's get to the email mailbag for the
week if you have something to say and
you feel like it's worth me checking it
out you can email info davidpackman.com
sometimes we will grab a YouTube comment
here or there or a Twitter reply or a
Facebook post or whatever the case may
be but not this week this week it is all
bona fide emails the first coming from
Chris in fact I received a number of
beautiful messages and some trolling
about my covid illness
which spread through the house like a
virus which it is uh last week Chris
said sorry to hear about your coveted
illness I hope you get better soon and
have no long coveted effects I got it
back in August for the first time and
luckily my sickness wasn't too bad other
than a headache for a day
thanks for everything you do and I wish
you the best for you and your family yes
I had it worse than a headache for a day
um in fact there was about a 28 hour
period where I was as sick as I can
remember being and I got all sorts of
different messages there was someone who
wrote to me and said that they put
hydrogen peroxide in their throat now
why am I saying it that way because
that's the way they wrote it you can see
that message on my Twitter and Instagram
they said they put it in their throat
and then something about lemon juice I
didn't do that I didn't introduce light
and heat inside the body I didn't use
bleach or any of that stuff
um and fortunately fortunately
it wasn't as bad as it could have been
it was pretty bad but it wasn't as bad
as it could have been and I appreciate
all of the messages from everybody
Sharon wrote in about what is a very
contentious topic and about which I have
made a decision
and I'm going to ask you to respect that
decision you don't have to like it but I
am going to need you to respect it
Sharon wrote in about interruptions and
Sharon said hi I enjoy watching your
show often Christo ivalis has a YouTube
show and when he shows a political clip
we see only the clip on the screen you
don't see my mug and he does not share
the screen or interrupt
have you ever gotten to see a movie with
someone and they talk or try to get your
attention during the movie they ruin the
movie I lose the joy of the moment when
there are constant interruptions it's
nerve-wracking and I generally end it
before the show is over I so wish you
would not interrupt your Clips or other
featured program thanks Sharon so listen
I get it there's two views on this one
is David shut up just play the clip and
don't say anything start to finish the
other view is I can get the clip
elsewhere the reason I'm watching you
David is for your commentary and so
manage it the way you want to manage it
I have made the decision because no
matter what I do people complain if we
just play Clips Long clips and I don't
say anything a lot of people say it's
not even it's like not even really your
show anymore you're just playing a clip
I've made the decision much like during
live streams where we watch a debate or
a rally I will open
I'm trying to offer something in
addition to just being a repeater of
clips and so I completely respect people
who don't want to see me or hear from me
during Clips there are lots of clipping
services and Twitter users who will just
post clips and no commentary I've made
the decision for the show for what the
show is that I will use my discretion
and sometimes you'll see my face during
a clip and sometimes you will hear me
say things and I will try to strike the
right balance as always with peace and
love you know I I will try to strike the
right balance and do everything that
everybody wants me to do the best
possible way but there are going to be
interruptions because that's the format
of the show and maybe Christo ivalis has
decided on a different format and that's
a beautiful thing we can all have our
formats and we love you Sharon that's
the important thing we received the
commentary with absolute peace and love
Jason wrote in and said I think the left
is in trouble
writing with the absolute disaster the
Republican party has become more and
more people in my Social Circle are
voting Democrat do you believe that as
more people move over to the left that
the left as a whole is in danger of
becoming more Centrist thanks for uh
taking the time to read the question and
for producing amazing content no I don't
actually I just don't believe that's
happening because there's two things
that are taking place here there are
people who vote for Democrats
because
they love the Democratic platform
and there are people who vote for
Democrats because they find it to be the
better of the two options that have a
shot at winning but the truth is that
the Democratic electorate is actually
far more to the left of where the
elected officials are so
it's already a very Centrist represented
party
and because of a combination of
different factors including the way
districts are drawn and so many
different things
what I'm actually seeing is a Democratic
party that at least on paper has
continued to move to the left now
whether the elected officials move to
the left sort of remains to be seen
still but I don't think that that's the
case I also think that this is a sort of
temporary aspect where
disheartened Republicans who don't like
Maga either don't vote or vote Democrat
I think eventually the Democratic party
is going to figure it out and they're
going to get away from Maga and go back
to something else so I don't believe
that that's going to be an issue I think
democrats should take victories while
they can so Sam wrote in about foreign
pronunciations and really is not happy
with me Sam said on the November 29th
show you pronounce the word Uruguay
in what I assume to be a Spanish Spanish
pronunciation accompanied with the
phrase Uruguay please folks
isn't isn't my audience the best this
makes me wonder
when you were talking to your
Argentinian friends about American or
English people do you expect your
Argentinian friends to pause their
native accents and pronounce American
names terms phrases in an American
accent and British names terms and
phrases in a British accent that's kind
of weird but or is this just an
expectation you wield towards Native
English speakers for example if your
Argentinian friend was to say to you I
think Donald Trump is even worse than
Boris Johnson in Spanish would you
expect them to use American and and
British accents for the names right
Donald Trump
Boris Johnson
um no I would not expect them to do that
listen it folks
I'm doing hours and hours of content and
I will interject flavor and part of the
flavor is Americans pronounce Uruguay in
what seem like absurd ways you're a gay
I found I mean it's come on so I'm just
it's just a reminder of the way that
it's pronounced Uruguay that's all it's
not to be offensive it's not to
criticize anyone it's not because I
expect Argentinian people to do
something when they say a British name
it's just a podcast and a YouTube
channel Sam all right let's all take it
easy it's just a little joke it's sort
of like when I will say my birth city of
Buenos Aires
I could pronounce it in these mangled
American ways but as Iris that is Iris
it sounds almost like a disease
and it is very much not a disease my
friends Buenos Aires
um we're just having a good time all
right let's not take ourselves too too
seriously Peter wrote In and Peter asks
an important question and says subscribe
is free yes David to subscribe is free
is that correct a membership costs but
to subscribe costs nothing if that is so
then tell people that this is reads like
a haiku
it costs you nothing to click on
subscribe it only indicates you affirm
the show if it costs nothing and you say
that over and over and over you'll reach
3 million in no time subscribe also
tells YouTube something positive is that
also true let people know that as well
if I've got it right let me know Peter
you have it a hundred percent correct
when you hit that subscribe button on
YouTube it is free
you are affirming the show
and it does tell YouTube something
positive which is recommend this chaps
videos to more people
so I say to you today
hit that subscribe button my friends
it's a very very important thing Stephen
wrote in and says hey David long time
listener here just something I thought
about the other day isn't Trump
announcing another run kind of like him
admitting but not admitting that he lost
in 2020 the whole system is rigged but
also vote for me if he truly believed
that it was rigged why would he try to
run again thanks for the time so this is
so great because they have answers to
all these questions and it's sort of
like a if you stupid answer stupid
stupid questions sort of thing you and I
might say
if you won in 2020 you can't run again
because you can't you can only you can
only do it twice you can't do it three
times they say well we were the rightful
winners based on the will of the people
but they made Biden president so we I
still get to run I get to do two terms
they figure that one out next one
if it's rigged why would people vote
if people voted in 2020 for you but they
gave it to Biden wouldn't it just happen
again why even bother to run and then
they say
we just need to win by enough
that they can't rig it ah they have an
answer you know whenever you think
you've got them in a logic pretzel they
always have an answer Ryan wrote in
about gift memberships one of my
favorite topics and says hey David and
team I'm wondering if it's possible to
gift memberships to specific people
I thought you mentioned it was a feature
when gift memberships were rolled out
but I could be mistaken yes here oh and
cheers and hope your daughter is feeling
healthier this week yeah she had the
easiest run of the covet it lasted like
24 hours it was crazy actually how
quickly uh she she was doing better
faster than everybody okay
how to gift a membership to a specific
person
you go to joinpakman.com
you sign up you check that this is a
gift button when you complete the
process there's a pop-up and it'll say
who do you want to send the gift to you
type in their name you type in their
email Bing Bang Boom it is that simple
my friends very very easy Josh wrote in
about the white paper David sir great
job on the building arguments without
Burning Bridges white paper despite
being an inherently racist document
that's a joke the paper provides
valuable insights and suggestions for
engaging in good faith conversations
about difficult topics I look forward to
referencing this document to improve my
arguments and methods folks the white
paper is available to you for free you
go to davidpackman.com guide
davidpackman.com guide it is free you
type in your email address we send you
the white paper eight or ten page
document I should figure out how many
pages it is
which contains a treasure Trove this is
an original document that we put
together on how to have conversations
with people with wacky political views
get them to reconsider their beliefs
without ruining the relationships check
it out
we have a great bonus show for you today
you can get instant access to the bonus
show by signing up at joinpakman.com
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not Dave Pacman yeah thank you and you
can use the coupon code 24 starts now to
get yourself a discount we'll see you
then or otherwise back here on Monday
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpakman.com NYC